i don't live the life of the streets no
more i follow god now the kids that's
out there in the streets nowadays they
don't have no respect for one another
right now these kids can't take a loss
they want to kill after every fight but
the federal government moved us out the
way in order to get that land now they
misguided all these low chairs they lock
that code they lack that coat
[Music]
you know i think just around this city
shreveport louisiana uh
you know you definitely
you talk about um legendary figures i
think it's it's fair to say that um
you know you're a legend around here uh
everybody knows you everybody has
something to say about you i guess i
just want to start by just just talking
about that about being somebody that
everybody talks about somebody that
everybody's got a story about somebody
that everybody knows when did that start
for you and and and what do you think
about that how does that make you feel
and in all honesty
things like that you can't plan those
things like that they happen that
necessity is a mother invention
so being short of stature naturally
and faced with a situation you have to
overcompensate because a person your
height or your statue are done height
done statue they would be trapped they
wouldn't be tried as easily as i be
tried so you pretty much have to do
things to make people dissuade them from
wanting to try you like that again when
was the first time you realized that you
had a reputation
i actually had a reputation for being a
nerd going to private school okay
and then
i was picked on for car and going to
private school because i lived in the
poorest area where it was considered the
bottom but my mom worked three jobs to
put me to private school so
guys like okay you go to less sister
school so i ended up having to fight
behind that
and some of the same guys i ended up
beating up later on they would have need
problems and i would have a solution to
the problem so they realized okay this
guy he can fight but yet and still
he's pretty smart and he will he willing
to help us and he's willing to teach us
so therefore i become known as a guy hey
he'll fight but he's also pretty smart
and we can learn this
that was one of the first things uh
you know the things i've heard about you
you know when when people talk around
the city when i first got here oh man
he's a knockout artist you know he's the
toughest dude around he's a killer he's
this he's that he's this but then i also
started hearing he's the smartest guy
you'll ever talk to
he got the biggest heart that he was
always down to help somebody that he
understood the law he was always putting
himself out there like that for other
people what is your reputation around
here again uh like i said necessity is
mother invention i knew the law because
i kept running into law each time i kept
running into a situation with the law
the old hedge in prison would sit and
the cdc would sit me down and say
you'll go don't go out there and play
basketball come here boy let me teach
you about your cage let me show you what
you got going on here and going on so i
took that and i passed that on to other
people so when they had situations that
i know they lost you were selling them
out i would take time to show them how
they make their lawyer work for them
because the average person don't know
that they lost your work for them so
they'll therefore they go for whatever
they love you tell them but out all the
things that i say
about all the reputation i had i only
did what was necessary what was needed
you know i'm saying i only deal with
necessary and needed in my situation but
the things that i like to be remembered
for is not
any violence that i may have occurred in
what i was trying to do because that
never was my ends to my meaning
any violence that occurred it happened
because situation happened and they
knelt to be dealt with
but that never was my objective i had a
goal try to get money for myself and my
family and get out of there and that's
what most of us had hey let's we wasn't
out there for the violence we went out
there for the fun and play we were like
hey let's make enough money so we can
get out the business and get out of here
and do something better for our family
that was our pretty much our goal so the
thing that i pride myself on with the
some of the code that we had as far as
respecting elders and helping children i
mean we used to buy buy clothes for
children and all things like
those are the things like we had we had
a
what we call a law because we never had
a leader nothing we just all dudes that
we loved each other we loved our big
homies and we listened but we always we
had certain colds and we'll sit here or
something to happen today
and then tomorrow
we'll come down and we'll talk about it
dawn or somebody say man you know the
old lady was stuck down there and 20
people paid by her why she didn't get no
why ain't nobody put no tire no car
from now on that kind of mindset yeah so
for now somebody don't let no 20 people
pass or leave up with them cheering
so now when we see a lady pull it over
we'll stop putting get her tie put the
towel in the cup she ain't got a tie
somebody go get a top that attitude that
that that sort of attitude about uh
community and inclusion and and taking
care of a family that's that that's one
of the reasons why i fell in love with
the people at the bottoms the most a lot
of the folks who are going to see this
ain't going to ain't going to really
know what the bottoms is can you kind of
explain what the bottoms is led better
heights shreveport louisiana can you
just sort of explain you know what that
community was like what it was like
growing up there
it was all red like it was a remnants of
old red light district when you have to
pour the stream downtown when the
sailors used to come downtown they just
come down there and party because that's
why he had the [ __ ] houses and all that
going on so the people that stayed there
unit was the poise of the poor's and
people come down and they party all
weekend down there in our spot then they
leave us to clean up the trash okay
ain't going on so therefore we always
stuck together because we never was uh
respected at other places when we go
places even when we go with parks and
recreation they said bottom bottom chair
and got to stick over there they didn't
want us with the other cheering they're
going on so did nobody else care about
us so we had to care about us each other
so that's why we said hey listen no
we're gonna we're gonna take care of
ourselves we're gonna take care of each
other yo mama needs uh a bill pay if we
go out and do something the first money
we get goes towards your mama bills the
second money we get then we can split it
up but the first money got to go toward
whatever our objective was when we leave
the house that night
and we just did we like say it was more
family oriented than people would
believe because we went by the old coast
and as you say we had nobody
ever had a set leader where nobody stood
up saying hey you got to listen to me
but we would listen to whoever had knew
the most about that situation
and we had like
if one person know more about this
situation than me then everybody will be
quiet and listen if if i know more about
the situation there's something about
legal they're going to come around to me
if it's something about this they're
going to come around to me or they're
going to run to some of the others about
whatever they feel the expertise we
didn't see him situation where we didn't
went
and said what happened and said well he
did this he did december and we tell him
man we love you but we're wrong we can't
we can't ride with that
we love you we're gonna make sure you
get well but we don't ride with what's
wrong and the the the way it was sort of
described to me first you know the first
time i ever heard of the bottoms or the
bottom boys anything like that you know
it was from the police you know when i
was here i started talking to you know
doing some research for a show and it
was described as the most
you know dangerous and ruthless and and
and vicious gang in the history of
louisiana what do you have to say about
that do you call it a game no no it
never was gang no gang affiliated you
know when you come down there you may
see bottom board wearing red you may see
a bottom board wearing blue he gonna
wear what he want to wear he made food
with some partners over here there's
some blood make food some partners over
here some crips nobody dictate who he
fooled with nobody dictated who he saw
but just respect the fact that we family
and let nothing come between that is
that also what you think made you guys
so powerful i think uh janet reno said
in the uh
when we was going to trial that we had
overcame several color barriers because
they associated us with bloods and crypt
because they seen dudes wearing red and
blue
so they said well bloods and [ __ ]
hanging together then i had some white
songs that was down there hanging with
me going on and so they said okay now
they they went across the
race thing but our thing was the bottom
is the bottom if you living in the slum
or you're living in a poor situation or
you're living in a low income situation
wherever you're at in the world you
still got bottom ideology because you're
trying to rise up from it so the bottom
is not so much as a place as an ideology
it's it's a lower state now i got to
build myself up but that's the whole
objective it's not
it's more like i said they didn't tow
down the bottom but they can't take the
bottom out the individual because they
stated us to hey man better my situation
better my not not just
some of the stuff that we see going on
right now it bothers us it bother all of
us because we love these kids out here
and these kids out here since the
shooting senseless this and going on not
respecting elders that's going on and we
know that's not how men operate what do
you feel is going on now that's just
completely different from the time that
you guys were coming the thing is
when you
when they scraped us
in
my my personal opinion now this strictly
in my opinion when they scraped us off
people who kind of had like a a moral
aptitude of doing things in a certain
way and make sure they enforce that
and when you take us out the way then
you got people that climb
to the top who who who never would have
been able to be there
these guys did not have the moral status
that they would have never been able to
climb to the top if people hadn't been
there with morris status because they
would observe that and say hey you
get your butt back down there you don't
you don't belong here because you're
gonna mislead a lot of people yeah but
those people when they scraped us out
the way
on them bunk charges and stuff those
people was able to rise to the top so
now you've got a generation of children
do you think you're still feeling the
effects of that because they pulled
y'all off the street but they did
because now
you had people that who who was ill
moral or didn't have the moral aptitude
that we had so now they up there being
leaders and so now they being leaders
and they telling guys forget that forget
yeah forget grandmama forget it joe blow
forget that that's what gangsters do and
the kids don't know no better they're
being misled
and and and man that's what everyone
always says you know when
when i mean yeah okay what's up mr goat
what's going on
hey
i was just asking the
band to describe what what what what the
bottoms was like you know and the bottom
boys being a a ruthless uh gang and then
and and how do you look at that
well i ain't gonna say we we it was a
ruthless game and they don't i don't
consider us as a game that's what bands
said i consider us as guys raised up in
the bottom
and uh
knowed each other all our lives
and we was all good friends from growing
up
just but for the game we was never a
game were you dangerous
well i'mma put it like this i ain't
gonna say we were danger but we weren't
gonna let nobody mess with us i just
look at it at a neighborhood
where it was real dangerous because
there were certain areas when i was 12
years old 11 years old on down but
really 14 years old on down it was
certain parts of the bottom i couldn't
go
it was just off limit i wasn't able to
to walk on the left side of the street
going east wow what was going on because
the clubs down there anything may happen
coming out when you're passing them club
people come at them club fighting
stabbing you don't ever know what's
going to happen
so when we was kid that's how we were
taught to stay away from the
area is that was that the same for you
yeah it's basically the same because
like i told you uh the bottom used to be
all red light district from the porter
street they just come down there had
[ __ ] houses you had all this you had a
club on two sometimes two clubs on each
corner and even when when they shut down
the port of shreve and the sailors
stopped coming down there other people
from other neighborhoods would come down
and party and everything so it's always
something going on down there but like
you said our parents and stuff to keep
us away from that where the prostitution
and stuff going they deliberately tell
us stay away from that and going on
because they know that they didn't want
us to be exposed to that but the thing
about like i said again about the bottom
is we wasn't no gang and we had didn't
have no leader the people that we loved
and respected people that we'll listen
to it and go know more about the
situation than me i'll sit there and
listen to him all day if i know more
about the situation than him he'll
listen to me that's what we be doing
about to exchange the information it
wasn't no he tell me what to do i tell
him what to do and nobody tell nobody
what to do if i was finna do something
in front of or got mad out of my mind
somebody made me mad not to do something
in front of old lady he he got the
authority as a man and as a person down
there saying hey hey come on bam calm
down you
you know what i'm saying did that ever
happen you you ever remember telling bam
to calm down well really
really i don't have to tell him i didn't
have to never tell him because we were
so cool with each other and we just
didn't ever really run into them
situation with each other i mean we
didn't had our words don't get me wrong
we had words when we was coming up
because that's just how it is in the
neighborhood
but
i know how far to go with bam i know i'm
not finna try to hurt him i know he
ain't gonna try to hurt me we gonna we
gonna argue today and tomorrow we gonna
be
doing what we do gambling together uh
laughing and joking like we normally do
we ain't like family yeah we won the
type of person that
i'm mad with bam today and i carry that
anger over
a year from now no it wasn't like that
we didn't do that with each other what
was your first uh what what's your first
memory of uh bam
me messing with when you at at uh steve
bennett stopped
tell me what that is hey man he's he's
always me watching us everywhere we go
because he was younger than me he's
younger than me so if i'm coming in in
the store he gonna watch me everywhere i
go he's watching and i'll be running him
i'll run him home and he'll you throw
something at me or do something you know
what i mean as we growed older we you
know we start being around each other
more and more and more and then we start
you know accepting each other relax as
family you know what i mean because i've
been knowing him since
bam was i'm what i told him i used to go
to private school yeah i told him when i
used to go to private school almost all
the way up until ninth grade
yeah my guys that mine around my age we
was always off doing something you know
what was your first memory of
of goat
that white that what with that white
delta
white death not now it was a bit a limit
yeah that white limited in fact he used
to win all my money all the time
yeah
she was like get up lit money i come
down there he weirded
and one of my strategies was okay if i
got a son in every neighborhood and
they're not allowed to fight each other
then it's gonna be easier for me to
squash stuff in different neighborhoods
cause all i gotta do is say hey get this
song from his son he'll get this on and
let them go there talk and squash a lot
of stuff which i did get a lot of stuff
what i always heard is that your sons
these th these youngsters that kind of
followed you whatever that they do
anything for that they have real love
for you and they they they follow you
anywhere well they look they look the
love that they had for me was called
some love i gave them
you see what i'm saying do you feel like
that's what love is in general and some
of them love you as much as they can so
you have to understand who you're
dealing with if a person has not ever
been exposed to love then he can only
give you his
ideology of love
so some people love it just sex other
people love is just following them so
certain people love his obedience so you
can they can only love you as much as
they can but you have to accept them for
that you got to accept them when you
bring them in there and then you have to
use that to bring situations into their
life to help them better if you bring
situation into life like i said i could
tell somebody you know and i call them
my sons because family i mean i'm i'm
serious about family that's why i called
the people in the bottom they were my
family because i seen people call people
homies and then stab him in the back
later on
so i didn't cut for that homie stuff
because i didn't see the reality in it
and it didn't fit how i felt about my
people that's what i'm saying so now
when you get to to where i start calling
my sons and stuff and going on i started
teaching them like a situation
hypothetically a situation where our son
got old son a couple of hundred dollars
and he said hey they did let's go dude
owe me 200 i'm gonna go up here and do
this and do that there you gonna do what
hold on let's okay son let's sit down
man you know i ain't gonna tell that
wrong and we get to add it up and i'll
write it down and add it up and then
i'll show him a list for like all
together we're gonna be out of 65
thousand dollars
burning you out paying for the other
sons to get out paying this here i'll
paying your lawyers so we're going to be
out of 65 000 for 200 do that make sense
he said he want to steal 200 and you're
pinning it out exactly how much that's
going to cost this is what it's going to
cost so so do you want to go here and
hurt this dude over 200
or do you want to let him pay you ten
dollars at a time and no food with him
no more and you that they they smart
dudes and they they'll sit there and say
yeah no dude that don't make sense i
know i went to get some good good good
advice before i went against it several
times you see what i'm saying because of
what because your emotion in your heart
literally well the people told me they
said listen you know i'm saying
hypothetical purpose hey man that ain't
worth it they ain't worth it that ain't
worth it bam bam this and that going on
and i heard a mountain every everything
but they told me that it wasn't worth it
but they didn't show me it wasn't worth
it how do you show you it wasn't worth
it just like i just showed you you fill
it out you break it down and you sit
here and say okay
you got this you got this going you got
this going and you got this going for
you all these are positive things
when you go do this
this little thing over these tennis
shoes you finna lose all this and lose
all this you know the value of this hill
for our way is the value of that so if
it don't add up why would you go do
something that don't add up what about
goat like what was his reputation around
uh the bottoms what's his reputation
around here i mean you you got people
who wear many hats in the bottom what
they is to one person they may not be to
a nut and so that's that's kind of
that's kind of hard that's that's kind
of hard what is he to you but gold is me
oh man that's that's my old head that's
you know that's my whole head i mean he
been been around i think he can play
basketball like michael jordan
but you know what i'm saying but other
than that though he's my old head now
like i said he'll tell you we have some
weird we didn't have some we had cause
i'm hard headed we didn't have some
rounds but if i ever need it then he
pretty much been there for me you know
what i'm saying and the thing about it
was you like it or not he pretty much
gonna tell you something if you don't
you don't think you don't think what
you're doing is cool he put him up gonna
tell you so you're gonna have to y'all
argue about it but he gonna he ain't
gonna sit back and let you do it and
don't say nothing about it i mean look
at some point you guys became the target
of the federal government you were the
target of the police in this city for
for a real long time and it seems to me
that there was a lot of fear you know
there was a lot of fear towards you
fear is i mean i mean let's go want to
say so
well well when it came to the police man
i'm gonna be honest with you man i ain't
give a damn about them for real you know
because i know they wasn't right and i
know they was they were racist you know
and i know they want to come in the
neighborhood and think they can do what
they want to do to you
and yes i had to grab a couple of them
and
and slang them a few of them but
they didn't know they didn't know it was
me though at the time though cause it
happened so fast that they didn't really
get a chance to see who i really was you
know what i mean
but
overall
um
the policeman
they were just they just wasn't right
man they were there and do you think
that that's part of the reason why y'all
needed to be
without you guys there i mean if you
have the
you know again the way that it's been
explained to me in the bottoms is that
you know the police could come down
there and do things to people and they
had been going on for years and years
and years and is that part of the reason
why y'all needed to be there and what
that one of the services that y'all
provided for the community well i think
that growing up down there and knowing
that how the police how the police
department was when we were scared
and i think as we got older we learned a
lot and we seen a lot
and we just wasn't about to let all that
happen to us
you know the
beating you up police is just bigger
that couldn't happen in the bottom it
wasn't gonna happen around us at the
time we was
you know like up in the late 80s and the
90s until we went to the no police
wanted to come down up down there and
beat up no one guy so was there was
there like a distinctive change in the
bottoms sort of between when y'all were
you know when when you were a youngster
when you were you were a little bit
younger to that point in the 80s like
what happened in the 80s what happened
in the 80s and 90s that changed or did
they change well what what what happened
was
we was we was exposed to more
better than just say our parents both
the police wives oh man them people with
some males down there man
they and we just i guess when we got up
in a certain age we just weren't going
to let it happen to us like that you
remember the fir your first interaction
with the police you're of course i
remember hearing the first interaction
with the police i remember my mom and my
dad getting into it and my mom was
complaining about why she couldn't go
nowhere with my dad
and my dad always had a
souped-up car and everything he was
telling because he got a small mouth he
said i got a small mouth
and when the police pulled me over
because he never stopped for the police
but he said but if police ever get me
pulled over that they're gonna say
something crazy and they probably gonna
end up killing me and because you with
me they're gonna have to kill you too
you see you remember him saying that to
me now you said it to my mama that's why
he told my mama that he didn't take her
nowhere with him because he knew what
the police said him and he had he had a
smart mouth and if they ever got him
jammed up and they tried to talk crazy
to him and handling him he was gonna man
up and they were gonna end up killing
him and by them having to kill him
they're gonna kill her too
but it's just like he was saying the
police is and this is this is like i say
the bottom
is ideology it's so many bottoms around
the world that people should be able to
relate to our stories i related to them
um
to nwa with nwa come out with their song
but if the police right it wasn't
because my sister is a police officer
but when she retired police officers it
wasn't it was
it was the closest ideology to
our association with the police that i
could i see
you that song that song
see all my songs that i chose is for a
reason they had a reason and so i would
like the song because
number one compton first thing they said
okay come tonight all i ever heard about
compton was they the gutter they just
they just slammed they dissonant and
going on so now i hear these people
singing and uplifting compton so i'm
like okay that's what they said about
the bottle when we like i told him we go
to the spa bottom people couldn't be
with other folks we they put us over
there so i said okay that's the way they
treat us but they uplifting their city
and they they proud of their area so i'm
proud of the bottom too so they look
just like they looked and comforted and
then you hear them say i see all these
news reported and all this him by the
police uh engaged this person and shook
their hand and gave him a turkey for
christmas and all that that didn't
happen down in my area i never seen that
side of the police because the police
knew that we was a minority area and we
was a low income area so they could get
their wreck off they could come down
there and beat people up because the
people didn't have money to hire no
lawyer people didn't have enough
knowledge about the law the foul suit
and it based on where they come from
they wasn't going to be held so the
police could actually get practice ass
whoopings on people down there and
nothing was going to happen to it and
all the people could do would take the
butt whooping and going inside the house
so when i seen somebody giving a better
description of the interaction of my
type of people with the police that's
why i gravitated to songs like that i
gravitated to song well
society is saying y'all are slum but you
proud you're proud of that slums you're
proud of that of yours you're making a
song about it and going on so things
like that was the reason that i chose my
music because i basically listened to
nothing rock and roll other than that by
rock n roll yeah that's that that's
basically where i live but you still
listen to rock and roll yeah i listen to
the motor
motorhead pantera uh corrosion
unconfirmed the type of negative yeah
yeah but you know that's that's what i
identify with about that and like what
he's saying that when the police come
down there and we not we we we we wasn't
we wasn't
we didn't do your role with the village
vigilante that the punisher thing yeah
we
allowed the police to do their job if
they did it right if they come down and
arrest the individual and did their job
we'll go we'll we'll either burn them
out or or whatever but if they come down
there and run somebody's head to the
wall or do something like that then we
was going we're going to interfere and
you had no you had no problem having a
problem with them no we had no problem
because i mean
one thing about it is we don't respect
uniform we respect men's now if you put
on that uniform the integrity that
you're supposed to have for that uniform
i can respect that but if you have no
integrity for that uniform how do you
expect me to respect something that you
don't respect
and you're the one took an oath i didn't
even take it out and so you i mean we
were talking a little bit before you
really carried that attitude into prison
yeah you carry that attitude you're
going to judge you as a man and if you
if you don't have that you don't have
that and then this thing that you were
saying that your dad said
that like if you if somebody acts a fool
in front of you know his lady if that
that happens he's gonna have to go all
the way with it and he knew that
decision going all the way in right now
i guess what i'm wondering is that
that's one of the wisest men i've ever
met i love that man with all my heart
i've known him very well so he can
attest this and i i'm saying this with
respect but you know one thing i've
heard about you from a lot of people is
you know that that that you don't mess
around and that uh you know if somebody
if somebody has a problem with you if
you have a problem with somebody you're
gonna handle it one way or the other and
i'm wondering one is that true and is
that something that you think has served
you in life but see you then you didn't
skip from
you you you know left a and b and c and
all that i i'd equate explain okay all
right first thing else i like to laugh
joke and have fun because i know how my
temper is that's the first thing number
two is i always try to resolve a
situation before it becomes a situation
because i know that if something
happened then i'm too small to sit
around and wait for somebody else to act
i i can't be retaliatory because i'm too
small
so i can't sit here i can't wait on
nobody to punch me and punch him back
because if they punch me it may not get
no sucking punch but i'm not gonna sit
here and wait on somebody to do
something to me if i know that it's
what they call the military i think a
pre-emptive strike yeah that mindset
overall how is that surgery
i mean it go 50-50 i got 11 bullet holes
in me i've been pronounced dead twice
but they also again i'm still alive so
through the grace of god so
and you're you're deeply respected
i mean i'd rather be respected for like
even when i was in prison i used to have
conversation with guys all the time
they used to talk tell me about
different things that i did which i
don't consciously pay attention or keep
tab with it
but
i'd rather be respected for the homeboys
i sent home straight other than the
homeboy that i keep in jail with me do
you think you can do one without the
other i mean it depends on your
circumstances it depends on the
circumstance you got to do what the hell
you got to deal with the hand that
you've been dealt which i'm saying the
thing is try to do everything you can to
keep yourself out of that situation yep
that's the metal exactly then this if
the situation arrives
then you pray about it and deal with it
i guess the quote the reason why i ask
can you get one with the other it's the
same kind of question i you know i asked
goat all to like i i see the position
that y'all are in
and i
i see such unbelievable uh power i see
such unbelievable uh
potential you i i know i know your
hearts i know what y'all want i know
that your love is for the youngsters out
there and i know that you know that the
people in this community and really all
over this country but in this community
right here the youngsters are in a bad
way right now and they got a lot of a
lot of obstacles ahead of them and
there's a lot of violence going on and i
believe in my heart that
because y'all have been in the places
that you all have been and you have
walked that walk and you've been in that
valley that you're in a position that
you can actually lift some people up and
change their minds see that's what i was
telling you earlier going on it's guys
when the federal government moved us out
the way in order to get that land
uh on these trumped-up charges and all
this different reasons whatever when
they moved us out of the way men's that
had
even though we may have been doing
illegal things at that particular time
we still had a moral altitude hey
respect other folks respect children
help help elder ladies with their cause
and going on we had that and when you
pull us out of the way people rise to
the top who would have never made it up
to the top around us because we would
have seen that they had no no more
aptitude they locked that code they
lacked that code and we would already
had addressed that they would have never
had a platform to speak to the cheers
you know but now when you move us out of
the way now they misguided all these
little children and the little children
running around here thinking killing the
grandmama and shooting the whole house
up with the baby and cheering is what
gangsters do and gangsters don't do that
and i don't blame the children for it as
so much because i can't do nothing but
love them because i was in the same boat
even though i had a different set of
teachings but you have folks like him
around you to let you know what was up
and but the thing about is i have to as
i always use teach dudes in in
penitentiary when i used to come to a
yard i go out on the yard and i get all
the dudes together and i used to tell
them i used to go over the rules with
them and a lot of them shake their head
like yeah man i know and i can look in
their eyes and tell they didn't know but
i could not hold them responsible until
i made sure that they know and they
heard it from my mouth so what and what
you're saying is the way that it was in
the bottoms and i know you would agree
that that you feel like the code was
laid out the code was very laid out they
catch you doing something i know man we
don't do that
we don't do that don't do that in front
of that lady don't do this here that
don't go in that lady y'all yeah the
federal government did this massive
sweep they had they had an objective in
mind they wanted to get you all off the
street it was one massive
one massive sting is that correct
yeah i pretty much say so what why do
you guys think that is what was their
motivation we already knew that they had
already had the works here for getting
that property what about 10 years
prior to them yeah they had we seeing
the groundwork all on it and then the
dude brother willie x did the radio show
on us he researched the records to find
out they had already been been drawing
the lines and drawing this for the for
the river boats and casinos casinos and
everything because they wanted that
property so now they had to turn us
from eliza into godzilla in order to
make us dangerous enough where they can
come down on us and get us with their
screaming stuff because there's nothing
that we did
that would made us supportive and got
sent away for that kind of time the
thing that we were doing we supposed to
got probably seven eight years eight
years here eight years here and we went
back out but that's that's not what they
wanted to do they wanted us out the way
because they know that like like even
with the old folks if i'm i'm not gonna
say i'm gonna just say one of my old
heads cause i gotta feel them from go
down down
one of my old heads if they go there
talking about uh tell old lady hey we're
gonna take your house you know
we'll do this him for you and we'll do
this here for you and you ain't got to
pay us back for a hundred years and
later 87 years old pretty much letting
you know that hey she gonna die and they
gonna get the property one of my old
heads would go to the latest list man
we'll lend you that money get that thing
fit get your office don't go stick
yourself in that kind of debt what
happened go what did the federal
government do what was their case and
how did they operate how did they
infiltrate what it what what because you
know but they they did what they done
knows they did it all over the united
states and i met some guys in prison
that got busted at the same time we did
whoever government hit they are at the
exact same time that we got here but the
only difference was they was on the east
coast
and we was down south and nazim was like
just say we got they came in the bottom
at um
at uh 12 11 40. that's when they come in
the bottom well they got them at 12 40
on the east coast like in virginia
and i'm like wow that's the hour that's
the day an hour and ahead of us so they
busted all us at the same time
and i ran up on guys like that up in
cumberland maryland yeah
and and and for the same sort of reasons
for property for for i don't know what
they reason was what do you think the
reason was here
just like bam i'm saying that boat the
those things
yeah they figured that if they didn't
get us from at the bottom people went in
the money in the boat coming down there
buying drugs and looking for women's or
whatever
they may got they probably gonna get
robbed or killed
and so they had to get us out from down
now yeah it wasn't no doubt they had or
they would have gone to spend their
money down there they were going to
spend their money down there and they
don't want the money going there they
want the money going to the riverboat
right where were you the day of the raid
i used to feed people up at my blue
house so i was up there cooking uh
um pork chop casserole
i thought they playing got the police
don't usually come and don't come in the
bottom so it's better because the police
at that point had pretty much
there was there was very little police
presence in the bottom of there now they
come through but the ones who come
through they they the two or three of
them that came through they played foul
with us and they they'll tell us hey man
we just tried to do our job and we we
didn't we didn't have no problem with
them doing their job just don't come
down there with that dirty stuff can you
explain her go to say but can you sort
of explain the the raid in your words
what it was what the federal government
did
i mean i was i was in that cooking
nothing said i was cooking the frying
the poke chop to get ready to make it or
a pork chop casserole
and dude was knocking on the dough
saying police so i started laughing
because i think it's somebody joking you
know how police make it to my dog cause
like i said i used to cook every i had
started after i got shot up there last
time i used to start just cooking every
day for people and they come by and they
eat so they said that
i like yeah all right y'all better get
away from that dog they're playing
before i started out i am so back at you
yeah yeah and they should go down there
my
my son who who's in there cooking with
me because i don't like the
i'm real when i'm cooking people food i
don't i don't like my hands to touch
nothing so he pouring it drank the gin
down my throat and pouring what's called
so
i'm watching i'm cooking and going rep
was in there so i'm going on so finally
and rep i said i should see who they
were playing at the door
and then rep said i still for real and
then next day you know i took out toward
the back room and i took out toward the
back room i hit the door but my big
snake
wouldn't let me get in it because
it must have felt the people because my
big snake blocked the doe and when i
sled blocked the door somebody tackled
me
and the lady voice said uh
just just be still bam bam we got you be
still bam man just they look at the
number just look at look at the letters
on on this shirt look at the letters on
this shirt
you know i say ain't no woman tackling
me this hard i i know that so i i twist
around and i can see the
later in the ski mask i could see the
blowing hair coming out on the ski mat
but it was another
a male officer had me wrapped around
and so
that's when they
they went back there and they finished
shooting my snake because at that time i
had like a nine foot of burmese python
and so they finished shooting my snake
then and they said no don't shoot the
snake and they went in and got my snake
then they went in
got the guns out the back room and came
on to the front they made us crawl out
on the bed and i'm like man how do you
do let the police come up on me and
that's that's all i kept thinking how do
you police how do you do man i said man
i got the holiday dudes and then i got
out and i crawled out and i looked
everybody in the bottom were laid down i
saw that explains everything it was was
explained to me one of the largest troop
movements
of american troops against american
citizens on american soil in the the
history of this country like 250 50
national guardsmen
yeah they had
helicopters you know ledbetter heights
it's a historic neighborhood you know
what i mean there's been some um
amazing people that come out of there
some amazing uh culture change the world
you know physically
it it got torn down after that did you
hear about that while you were locked up
what does it feel like now how many
years were you locked up oh 27 lit over
27 years you know coming home and seeing
the bottoms now you know what is that
i heard about it but like i like i
probably mentioned before
when i'm in jail i i cut off i cut off
everything you know my sister like i
said she's a police officer and a
minister and a pastor of a church going
on so she's
and she at the bottom but she's not
going to tell me nothing
concerning
anything illegal or anything
so i never even really heard nothing of
it and not she's the only one used to
basically i had contact with you she
sent me my allowance and uh
hug my friend by they sent me my
allowance they sent me the inquisitor so
that i could read the
shreveport paper inquisitor they made
sure i got that so i can get were you
reading it
yeah you knew you knew that it got torn
down yeah but what was it like when you
came out and you saw it well now when i
came out and they took me down and i the
dude who doing the documentary on me
i went in every spot that i had pictures
of
and i took pictures in that exact same
spot where now it's nothing
or it's old shack there and going on
just to show
what the time had eroded how time had
eroded and going on to
because we sit in in prison and the time
don't pass for us like it passed for a
lot of people and unfortunately a lot of
times we think we don't come back to the
things that we left out there
and that was a cruel reminder that you
time still continues on while you're in
jail but me personally i have to
based on the fact that i'm not a
submissive
i can't really especially in some
environments i've been in i can't you
know
i can't
be focused on the outside and do what i
need to do on the inside yeah i
basically had to shut that out with me
up from day to day
and how about you
what about you when you first seen it oh
well i saw it back in 99
uh when i came back to get
and 99 and uh and uh us marshall said
let me take you down through the bottom
and so when he told me were they trying
to be cool with you or they well
the marshal that took me back to court
to get recently they always was cool
with me
they brought me through the bottom and i
seen how everything had been towed down
and stuff so i was more or less knowing
that you know
it was changed did that hurt
well it hurt it
you know but once i got out
out of jail completely then i knew that
life bring about a change you know
that's just part of life thing change
ain't nothing gonna stay the same
forever
and then i embraced it what do you think
about in terms of um violence on the
street do you think that there's a do
you think that there's a currency to
that you know it's something i i i was
talking about the with these cats in
baltimore i think there's something
about the police
where they feel like with each other you
know if you're known as the kind of guy
who will engage in violence if you're
known as the kind of guy who who commits
violence on the street that gets you a
certain sort of um camaraderie gets you
it gets you the respect of your peers on
the police force and i think that that
causes sometimes
police to be violent and i'm just
wondering what you feel from from your
community the currency of that
you know i'm gonna put it like this in
here back when we were young when we was
talking about how the police was i get a
police credit back in in back in the
days when we was on the street
because
they would not shoot you in your back
the police is back then if you run away
from them they ain't finished shoot you
in there in your back
they ain't gonna even shoot that gun at
you period
only way they gonna shoot the gun at you
back then you have to do something
with a weapon on you towards them
but the police of the day they are
cowards they are real cowards for real
any police any man shoot another man in
his back as a coward that's simple is
that
if if i'm in tour with a guy
and i got a gun on him
and he turn and walk away from me ain't
nowhere in hell i'ma shoot that guy in
his back
i ain't gonna do that that's that's do
you see that do you see that same thing
on with uh the kids on the street with
the with the kids messing around in the
game you see that same kid on the street
shoot another kid in the back he's a
coward
do you see more of that now than do you
think that that's changed now that it
was one year because the only thing i
ever hear about is the killing after the
fact you know like if i'm i'm not in the
streets no more i don't
you know i may holla pass through cause
i got my own life i'm living now
i don't live the life of the streets no
more i follow god now so
the kids that's out there in the streets
nowadays
they don't have no respect for one
another they if i look at
guys
when i was coming when we was coming up
and i know guys from practically every
neighborhood
and no matter what them guys was doing
we all had respect for one another
we like bam say we know how to
communicate with each other without
trying to kill each other you know what
i mean
but to look at a person
and say i don't like him
and then
he'd say something to me i'd say
something to me didn't i want to kill
him
no man that ain't that ain't life yeah
yeah that ain't what life is all about
you're gonna disagree with uh you could
have a disagreement with anybody without
killing them
there's something about uh i remember
you once said to me but that that that
uh growing up in the bottom though you
you
you needed to learn how to fight good
like you need to learn how to handle
something like what's what i'm trying to
get at like what does that get you
well it don't get you nothing but that
you could go places and people's gonna
respect you when they know you were a
fighter if they know you'll fight back
and anybody in the bottom know you'll
fight back you can hang out with them
guys them guys don't want nobody around
them if they don't know if they want me
to fight yeah
you never know if i run up on some guys
somewhere
you think i want a guy with me that
ain't gonna fight you're gonna help me
fight yeah if i have to if i need help i
need help yeah if two or three guys i
ain't gonna beat up no two or three guys
now i might get lucky and get two of
them
three or four there you go i want
somebody with me that i know gonna stand
there if they gonna beat us up they're
gonna beat us up together you know what
i mean
but
these guys no they don't fight no more
we was taught to fight but she was also
taught to respect the fact that if you
lose ain't nothing wrong with losing as
a man
see these kids right now they lose the
fight and they go get their gun they
want to kill the dude as long as you
fall back and you lost as a man we was
taught to respect that too yeah at least
you didn't wrong yeah these fights that
you lost allows you to get better at
your ability to fight
right now these kids can't take a loss
they want to kill after every fight one
of my partners down there you know from
california he sit there and we thought
he was him and this old man
old man out of philadelphia we see him
going to sail we thought he was fighting
old man
and we we here we hear them fighting the
punches going on in the sail man we i go
get a couple that's home but we go to
the door man we say look here gee you i
know
we you know you ain't we we snatched the
door we know you ended up fighting it
old man and he said no man and then
he had to pass he was hitting the pass
he said man i'm from california man i've
been shooting since i was 11 years old i
never had the chance to learn how to
fight he said y'all dudes he said
philadelphia dudes know how to box the
dc dude know how to bark y'all southern
dudes it's [ __ ] strong he said man i
gotta learn how to fight
i mean and that's true he said y'all
selling the dudes are [ __ ] strong yeah
that's what he said he's y'all still do
[ __ ] strong man y'all we can't i can't
eat i gotta learn how to fight he said i
never had how did you learn how to fight
so good because i heard i heard you're
pretty legit i don't think i'm i don't i
don't think i classify as a good fighter
i just classified being tenacious i
won't stop because i mean i lost with
two bit you know two bit yeah too big
putting my bicycle on flat and that that
country song gone could fight that
song's gonna beat me up seven times in
the eighth time every time he come down
and i told him you wanna we gonna fight
her you gonna fix my bike i lost every
fight we had but i bring that bike right
to him that eight times he said man come
on go get that bike let me fix it
[Laughter]
you know so i i wasn't about always win
i was just tenacious i wasn't gonna
if you get tired for me then you can
kiss the baby yeah there you go there
you go
and uh i mean what happens when you when
when you're looking at a sentence when
you're looking at a sentence like you
guys were looking at
what does that do with your mentality i
mean you told me that you know you had
to sort of be a different person
in there than you are out here obviously
did that come immediately
i'm going to say this right and and i i
didn't realize what i had until i got to
the federal system
because i i took angles i took for
granted
but we went to trial
we were the same people we was on the
street
we were supportive of each other we
dealt with each other we going on with
each other and when we got in there and
do some man i be talking good about my
co-defendant man man
you talking when you go defending man
forget that my cody felt like hold on no
man my co-defender went to trial with me
i ain't got nothing bad to say about my
co-defender all my we all with the trial
together going on then i had to explain
to them man the dude who testified
against you is not your co-defendant
because you're co-defending me that he
defended yourself against that charge
with you as your co-defendant against
that charge if he took the prosecutor
side and he's not your co-defendant so
that was that was uniform among all the
people yeah hey man when that when them
dudes got there they told dudes who was
telling me from baltimore all these
mother dude like man we were watching
y'all try man we ain't never seen that
many dudes stick together to get into
wow how many people was it it was all
together with 13 of us and and everybody
nobody said nothing on anybody nobody
said nothing they went got dudes from
other places when got my brother went
got people from other places facing
other joys and brought him in half of
the people we didn't know had the people
we had their numbers just spoke to or
took a picture with
but yeah they didn't
nah you you had opportunity i remember
they they they come to me with deal they
come to go with deal
and
man you can take that it should why
would i give a man some time i don't
want hmm no no we don't do it like that
i'm not gonna get on man no 35 years for
me to go home in five years
and was that something that all you guys
just
is that's just who you are when the when
they asked me says you know is there
anything you want to tell me
i said yeah give my lawyer
and he said you're going to get a you're
going to get a whole lot of time i said
i don't give a damn and i walked off did
you not give a damn i did cause you just
knew there i mean there was just no way
you were gonna say anything against
anybody i wasn't gonna say i'll get
nothing against no no i'm gonna tell you
this though
really maybe he really he really uh had
me laughing at it because he said you
know what man he said gold i ain't gonna
lie to you he said man i really thought
you were gonna say something
why did you say that cause i hadn't
never been in jail no you don't know
all the stuff i used to do i just never
got caught
what was your sentence uh 29 years or so
you get 29 no no but but that what were
you sentenced to 29 29 years
and four years and four months so you
guys said this is 29 for and you had
never been locked up before you never
even been in jail well i've been in jail
for like gambling and yeah yeah up to
the city jail but just for us
when you're in court and they gave me
two or three years or something like
that i went to the farm school when i
was yeah yeah i remember but that ain't
nothing else but i'm talking about just
food going to jail
no i had never been to jail so they
would took a veil they were tickling me
with valve i said bam just think about
all the stuff i used to do i said i just
never did get caught doing nothing i
mean me and dove's up there me and
daughter
i said
dawson that's when you come over there
you should listen man all right listen
i'm in this here too man i ain't trying
yeah
i said that's all goddamn yeah he made a
believer out of me
that's what they done they come to me
and they offered me five years to say
not not tell the truth on them but to
say some stuff against him and go and
done that they had
in the book that's when i tried to slap
my lawyer i tried to slap my lawyer
try to slap him yeah i tried to slap him
they started making me come in with with
the with the hand because he was trying
to make you lie on on on yeah well he
had brought this deal to me and then i
had this white guy named joe ellen bound
he did he did the book called the
secrets and tools of post conviction
relief and he was down there in a cell
next to me and i had my wife bringing
him a tv because she had to have
everything brought to you in the city
and he was telling me man you need to
get rid of that lawyer
filed to get rid of the lawyer and they
gave me a hearing on it and then the
lawyer was explaining or elton elton
ritchie was explaining to me listen man
you're my client i got to do what's best
your best entry he said the prosecutor
offered me this deal to give you five
years you would testify to these things
against them he said but i it's my job
he said i don't represent them i
represent you it's my job to bring that
to you so i didn't mean he said i told
him i used to be a he used to be a
police down their name with mustache he
said i used to be a police down there he
said actually he said judge didn't mean
you get into it cause i told you i said
you're gonna need to pay us some money
up front because these guys here are
going all the way
and you threaten to put me in the
basement he said yeah yeah you did say
that thing going on he said yeah he said
but man if you're going all the way to
trial i'm going all the way with you he
said but i have to
bring this to your attention he said i
had the brain to deal with offered and
that's when the prosecutor said you know
what i'm gonna make sure you get the
most time at all and then that's when
they wouldn't got my brother said that
i'm gonna make sure you got it gonna get
the best on the wall you know kind of
meeting you when you had first got down
and you just seemed like you were full
of uh
just gratitude and and um i've often
said about people about you you you got
peace of mind unlike anybody i've ever
really met you you know you've had real
sort of
beautiful triumphs and and beautiful
things kind of happened in your life
since you got out and then you've also
had some tragedies you've been through
but what did you learn
well
being locked up
you know you you uh what me by being my
first time
you know
i wasn't trying to let the time do me
you know
i know i learned how to adjust to the
situation
and uh i got along pretty well with all
of the guys that i mostly come around
you know because i like sports a lot of
them love sports we play ball play
basketball well i didn't play football i
was too old for that then but basketball
i stayed on that basketball court and
handball i did a lot of working out and
just kept myself physically in in shape
you know
then i started doing i was doing a lot
of reading and stuff
and
really i was trying to keep my mind out
of the prison system
i wasn't trying to be know
uh what you call it uh
have a mind of just staying incarcerated
you know i just tried to keep myself
away from that i stayed i did a lot of
my time on the phone talking to my kids
kids mama and all that type of stuff few
of my friends and stuff like that but
overall i just tried to keep myself in a
positive attitude all the time i didn't
like negative
round me in jail when i come around if a
guy come around me and i hear him
speaking a lot of negative talk i didn't
want them guys around me so i stayed
away from round now were you like but we
were you like that before you got locked
up well i always been a positive person
and was when i was doing wrong i i i
always have been positive no matter what
and i don't like people i don't i just
don't like negative stuff around me
and and i more rather just stay away
from around you if it got to be
conversation always negative yeah i
never felt like i wasn't coming home but
and bam you you you felt like you you
you didn't feel that way right no we was
kind of opposite in our thinking yeah
i'm real interested in that what was
your thinking i think it was i mean all
i got is today
you know i was dealing with it one day
at a time you know i know you you ended
up in super max but how did that happen
like what what what went down well
supermax
super max came
i'm not gonna say ironically because
everything god do for a purpose
through the long situation i mean being
locked up the first day like i said my
sister was a police officer and she was
a minister
they went got my big brother and put my
big brother up on the stand for three
days and got him to tell a lot of lies
against me
and our homeboy stuff that he that he
never even seen
didn't ever even happen
and so it was hard to grow up in the
bottoms too yeah yeah that's what my
brother would
been that angola being there to lose
down the state golden little boxer
everything
but
that that was the hardest thing so when
i hit jail i was angry when i hit hit
floors i was angry i had a lot of anger
he scattered needles but finally got me
some tattoos because i was so angry
and everything you know i like i used to
tell people all the time i'd rather be
shot with a gun than stuck with a needle
but anyway i got in there i had a lot of
anger going through this and my sister
was always telling me that i had to
forgive and for let that go and forgive
and all this and that and she thought
she loved both of us because we both
were and most your anger was about your
brother and your brother testifying
again yeah it was it's basically about
him because he's my big brother i looked
up to him and everything and then he did
that to me and i did everything i could
for him so in dealing with that my
sister she she would stay no matter what
she write me a letter to send me my
allowance and i tell her don't tell me
that no more she said it that was gonna
always be in the letter she gonna she's
gonna put some scripts in there she made
sure i had bible she gonna put scripts
in there she kept on she kept on until
about like
last 12 years i sit there and i got to
pray and i said well god you telling me
i don't do i don't do the hypocrisy
thing i see you telling me forgive
somebody i don't know how to forget i i
forget this dude to do get up here and
do this here to me
and all i did for this dude i said i
don't know i said i don't know how to
play like i forgive him so so so help me
and so i had three dreams
in a row
i had a hand pick up a hammer
and the hammer and the hand would hit me
in the head with the hammer then throw
the hammer down and i would run over
there and start hitting the hammer while
the hand was moving behind me
and then so on that third time then i
said why are you fool-wise you instead
of fighting the hammer when it's the
hand that did the damage to you then
that's when i told it to my sister she
said that's that's god showing you that
your brother was just a tool
used against you your brother wasn't
your actual enemy the devil was your
enemy and your brother was the tool he
was against you so i prayed and prayed
about it then that that gave me an
ability to bear to forgive my brother so
now
i said okay if i can forgive my brother
then i could forgive everybody who
testified against me because they were
used in the same fashion
so that's when i took it from there and
i said okay well the slate clean with me
everybody i forgive everybody who folks
because in in actuality the way we live
some of these people mama had dope
charges simple dope charges and the fed
threatened these people mama with 30
years and 20 years if they didn't
testify against us and now me i came out
to jail i pretty much got my health i
pretty much got my own sanity
if somebody mama had got 35 years for me
i couldn't say that yeah i went crazy in
there you see what i'm saying so so
anyway
i dealt with that and uh
got past
i had called myself changing my life so
when i changed my life
they put me in a sale with they got this
crazy dude that they tried to put us put
in the cell with me and he was a mental
patient
and i told them constantly cause i had
tied up my ceiling because he tried to
rape his little white kid on the
compound they put him in there with me
so i had
tied him up and and and throw them out
to sail so anyway
when they started the smooth thing they
bring the mental patient they kept
putting him in the cell with people and
what they would do is they'll put him in
there and then they'll stop giving him
his medicine
and when they stop giving him his
medicine then he go paranoid and going
on so when you cuff up to go to wreck
he'd either
cut you with a razor or why you cuffed
up or he beat you with locks and socks
so everybody had started beating him
first so he was all beat up and
everything so when they tried to put him
in the cell with me i said nah man cause
i had made up in my mind
then i wasn't gonna hurt nobody else so
i said no matter what i'm not gonna hurt
nobody else so they tried to force him
in the cell with me
and i wouldn't take him in the sale of
me i said because i'm not gonna let him
hurt me but no i'm not gonna hurt
anybody else so they tell me you're
gonna take him in the sale we're going
to put you in restraints i said well
that's what y'all gonna have to do they
put me in restraint for 45 days for
refusing them as a seller
and that's why that's why did they put
you in restraints because i refused to
manage to sell it and by me refusing him
out of the ceiling that was starting it
was starting now what they call that
domino effect other dudes started
turning down they selling instead
because what they was doing it was
basically for money but yet still when
they claim that special management unit
is for people who so violent they have
to have a certain amount of violence so
they were putting people in there who
was not compatible with each other like
when motown killed this ceiling like
five sailors had got killed right while
i was there and that's when my lawsuit
went into play because that's why i
can't feel nothing in my hands right now
because
by the time they took the restraints off
me after 45 days
some some of the inmates had contacted
the lawyers and told him because i was
writing when i see him do something to
somebody else i would write to lawyers
and so some inmates wrote the lawyers
and said hey bam i'm always writing you
for the stuff they do other folks now he
didn't disappeared we didn't see them in
28 days so finally they got down there
and they had to go get the governor of
pennsylvania and the government of
pennsylvania sent their assistant down
there and told them they had to release
me from restraint but they couldn't
release me that day because i had been
in restraint so long
that my skin had grew over the handcuffs
so they had to
soak my hands in the red stuff
and then they had to cut my skin open to
get the head and get the handcuffs out
so that's when they let my lawyers got
died and they took my case and that
lawsuit been going on so
when i wouldn't drop the lawsuit they
would just come in and like
a lot of the good like i said a lot of
police all of them wanted dirty like
let's show them they're coming to him
say man you know they gonna come visit
you tonight
i said yeah he said yeah be ready
then
they're coming down there richland
cuff up i said cover up for what
come up you just threatened my officer i
just threatened your officer
and they're in they're going on i cuff
up and then they take me down and they
rough me up put me restrained and that's
when one of the lieutenants lieutenant
bernard told me said hey listen
man i don't trust some of my co-workers
he said listen
do not be coughing up because when you
cuff up they do not have to have a
camera on you
if one of them something's gonna hurt
you going down that step if they worried
against your against your words the
lieutenant told you this lieutenant he
so he said refuse handcuffs
he said because he said i don't trust
some of my coworkers he says
these young young lieutenants they they
gung-ho he said so listen you always
been straight with me that's what they
tell my sister when my son used to call
that everybody listen
he one of the most respectable dudes i
ever met he said if you talk to him
he'll stand down but if you're in the
right
you want something dead about it he said
but if you if you go to him talking
crazy and going on then
he gonna gonna make you go all the way
he said but if you go talk to him and
write he said i never had no problem
with him and lieutenant bernard
told me he said i'm telling you make
them bring the camera make them do the
full everything he said because i'm
scared what i'm gonna be taking you down
in step they're gonna be them broke
their neck and then they're gonna set so
i had to start making sure that they
they
i couldn't cover up for them i had to
start making sure they go get the camera
and everything and they go get the
camera and once they get the camera they
gasp me and they take me out but at
least i had the camera on me so
therefore they couldn't if they could so
then that would be the process every
time they wanted you every time almost
200 times
so they come to your cell
they come to your cell they tell you you
need to leave they say cuff up you say
i'm not gonna cuff up now what they'll
do they'll come to sail and say first
they come to me and they try to talk me
into dropping the lawsuit they told me
they would put me on the lawsuit the
original lawsuit after 45 days they told
me they would put me on the compound
they would get me out of special
management unit they put me on compound
and i said no what about changing y'all
tactics and the way y'all deal with
people if y'all ain't gonna do that then
they don't need to talk to me so then
they come back again and they said
listen we can get you all uh i think
they call it down with departure they
said we can help you with a downward
departure and going on by you not
causing the government
not costing the government we could get
some time cut off your centers i said no
i said if they ain't not going to change
they say i don't care what they trying
to give me if they're not going to
change it's him for these old people and
all these other people that going on and
i'm not going for it and i stuck to it
and
that's what they ended up getting me
sent to uh or florence they said because
when i started doing that other inmates
stopped saying well i ain't gonna ain't
gonna do my sailing man you know y'all
gonna have to do me i ain't gonna do my
sailing so cause
like i said about five silliest had been
killed in like a year period of time and
and deuce was cutting as soon as they
said let's get in and you know because
the police would sit there and say i
don't see no blood
during that same process guys refusing
to cuff up yeah they were getting killed
in that process yeah
i got there i got new paper clippings of
my lawsuit and everything they show you
how many was killed and
and so bam so you you so you know that's
coming in
you know you you you know these other
folks being killed by doing that they're
coming into you telling you to cuff up
and what are you telling yourself there
just ain't no way you're gonna break you
just no you now you can't do that there
because if you ain't got a cause to
stand for then man you just i mean ain't
worth living
it ain't worth living if you ain't got
something that you believe in enough to
die for it
so and that was just my thing i had made
up in my mind all the stuff i did for
the devil
i had made up my mind to god that i
wasn't putting my hand on nobody else
and even when the officer who who i got
into with they said what they want to i
never never put my hands on them to
suffer what you suffered in that
situation and then to make to to follow
through with this case and actually make
that change you could keep that from
happening to somebody else
well what they did was obama had bought
this prison in thompson you remember he
bought thompson toasted millionaires he
bought that prison in thompson illinois
obama had bought this prison but they
hadn't staffed it so what they did was
they took the smooth
and they [ __ ] all the smooth down and
then they shifted all the who they shed
all the smooth down special management
unit the ones that were using the
tactics that that that i suffered they
shed all those down when i lost when i
lost who got in like
into one of the final phase because i
they asked me to let him make a class
action so he made it class action to
include everybody who couldn't couldn't
go all the way like i went so now what
they did was they opened up thompson and
they staffed thompson first with the
cadre then they staffed it and what they
did they took shut down all the smooth
and they put all the uh uh
all the special management unit inmates
in the thompson prison then they took
all the stuff that we had suggested
they took all the stuff that we
suggested because i had suggested in
bringing people on the range and putting
them in the sales and let them be by
themselves until they can get a
compatible seller and then get together
with them make sure the ceiling was
compatible to give them a couple of
weeks and then put them together as
opposed to just stuffing them in the
sale with somebody right off the bus and
going on to decrease the possibility of
somebody hurting each other and then
they reduced the time from it being an
18-month program to a nine-month program
so everything and they got more
educational programs and they got more
outside wreck so now they did all those
things so when we went before the judge
they said
your class action suit is mutant because
they're no longer is the smooth because
they moved them all to thompson and all
the texts and tactics in which he was
complaining about has already been
addressed so my lawyer says
we have we won
even though they made our cl my class
actions move we won because we got them
to do everything did you feel like you
won
well
if the inmates came out better then i
won't yeah but i still got my punitive
suit going on for my personal damage for
me is that against the is that against
the individual officers that did it yeah
yeah against the 14 that did it i still
cut my eyes that's why i had to wear the
shades i got photo all the gas they used
to leave it like when they gasped me
they would they wouldn't wash my eyes
and so the gas
scarred my corners or something so it's
like
that's why i like i got photo system to
clog it with light hurting my eyes
that's why i have to wear these
all the time
was there anybody for you and your your
time locked up
did you meet anybody that that you feel
like changed your life or inspired you i
met this one guy
oh his name was john he had been locked
up like
27 years when i first met him i used to
talk to john john was a muslim he had
ended up being in the nation
islam
and i used to talk to him all the time
and he used to give me some real good
knowledge about situation around the
prison you know and i used to listen to
him he was about john was about six a
six six
six five six six
and strong as a ox
and uh i learned a lot from him and uh
i think i don't know if john's still
alive or not because they sent him off
to a
medical prison and when i made it home i
called his sister and she said he wasn't
doing well the counselor had started
getting
messing with him
and he's supposed to been getting ready
to go home
way before folk way before me you know
what i mean
so
i don't know if he alive or not
today but he sort of you know he was an
inspiration to me i really used to
listen to him yeah but my son's
grandmother yeah she really used to tell
me about praying i was listening to a
bad about the uh forgiveness yeah and
that's what i that's what i used to pray
for pray all the time
and then i asked god to forgive me for
all of the stuff them guys did
and anything i did to anyone else i
asked for forgiveness and that looked
like it just made my time that much
easier and simple yeah i mean it was
like
like it was like just waking if you wake
up in the morning it was all right yeah
you know what i mean and that's how i
used to leave with my days yeah got
along with i thought get in love with
everybody yeah yeah well i
mostly got along with everybody anyway
yeah you know what i mean because
you know i know how to adjust the
situation you know yeah and how how many
years has it been now that you've been
home 10 years uh-huh 10 years
in a couple of months uh-huh yeah
yeah
yeah man that's great and what's most
important to you right now what's what
what what's most important your family
my family my family is most important to
me right now my children my
grandchildren my wife
you know my friends and their families
and church
god
i give god all the praise all on all the
glory because i think that if
when i came home i said i was going to
go to church
right i ain't saying i'm going to go to
church every sunday
but i said i was going to go to church
and thank god
and i ain't been our church since no
more than when that pandemic came up
yeah other than that
i've tried to be in church every sunday
praise him giving him all on all the
glory yeah and just magnify his name
yeah that's what i do yeah and that's
without god i don't know
when i came home without him
i don't know if i would be
where i'm at today yeah because i don't
know if i would have went back the other
way you know what i mean yeah but with
him i know he guide me in the right
direction what do you want to do now
basically my main thing whatever i do is
going to be in the line of serving god
number two is i want to reach out to the
children and try to do something
constructive they try to give back a
little bit from some of the things that
i may have been a part of and also like
i said i go downtown on mondays and two
to pass all savages to the people just
to try to get back and i try to do my
videos to the children to try to reach
them and you know the thing is to try to
reach them out of love because you can't
sit here and
try to tell somebody something about
doing something different with their
life when you actually have them
invested into their life
and that goes for politicians or church
people whoever if you're sitting up
there in that nice church house and you
ain't are you sitting up there in a nice
politician building you're going on you
don't know the pain or what these people
going through and you're not actually
investing time money or whatever into
their life then you really don't have no
say so what what what can you tell me
is when i'm hungry my stomach is
growling and you sitting there your nice
office with your nice suit up going on
but you telling me this and that what's
good for me if i create a hotline we
don't want no names don't want no
information just say okay what's the
situation here well man what about if a
dude step on this dude's shoes and
they're going on okay do step over to do
a shoe what to do well do do want to go
back and bless him all right the dude
who want to go back and bless this dude
what do we have going on in his life do
we have a mother do we have a child we
have a job do we have a car so you find
out the things that you got how you feel
about them oh he loved his mommy he
loved his child he loved it she love
this okay
now you get to the point where you ask
him say well let me ask you this him at
what point in time in this dude
situation did he stop loving his mom and
his children and all that there
no he still loved him how can he still
love him if he were to forsake all them
for about sixty dollar tennis shoes
i said now you know what i'm saying you
can't be a genius in a dummy at the same
time so which one is it
and then you get him to think about this
you know and if you stop this guy from
going killing somebody you just saved
two lives and two families from
suffering the people you were closest
with
like right now
those people who are still out there in
florence or them people that you're real
close would you do you feel like they're
like-minded i mean like how long
i've been i told you i've been around
oh
larry hoover wayne perry jeff ford
all of those individuals are
those dudes are not the people that they
used to be
those dudes have a different mindset and
people are not like giving them the
opportunity they're judging them about
what they used to be wayne perry
that man is the dude he's got a good
heart i don't care about how many people
he murdered or whatever the dude has
seen a change and this dude they do not
give him the platform because if you
give him the platform he would sit there
and actually talk down some of this
stuff that's happening same thing with
larry hoover larry who would
i
he would talk down some of this stuff
that's going on he don't support that no
more the man constantly would tell me he
said man i'd rather be out there on the
street picking up canned and be a legend
in prison that's that was his exact word
to me he didn't want to start doing my
legal work when my co-defender went home
big dumb this dude these dudes has got
different mindset you get that man
opportunity to come home that man come
out here with a different mindset he
gonna be able to reach a lot of children
but they don't want to give him that
opportunity because and i can only i can
only think that they really don't want
the problem solved because it's not
economically sound for them
to get the problem solved they make more
money
being able to lock people up by having
detention centers instead of having an
attention center where they give
attention to people's situations and try
to help them they can just lock them up
and make 75 a day off but that dude
larry who with jeff ford and all them
dude old dudes
and they what they was in they passed
and all that those dudes got a mindset
for the communities they don't like what
they seeing going on out there you know
what i'm saying i mean this is i ain't
talking what somebody else told me i've
been around these dudes with my partners
i've been around these guys these dudes
are solid man these dudes ain't changing
just like with me these dudes ain't
changing their way because they scared
of nothing they changed their way
because they realized it don't make
sense no more they hate to see these
children going through what they're
going through i give them respect them
dudes is sincere they got a sincere
heart ain't nobody make them do nothing
them do to make a country decision and
they're very intelligent mans you know
what i'm saying and i know i believe in
my heart bates don't talk to me they
didn't have to lie to me
they didn't have to lie to me i accepted
them the way they was
and them dudes sit there and
and would come some of the conversations
wayne perry was talking me down all the
time he's talking me down sometime and
the folk get me mad this is just he's
not about that he see the dude he was
young when he when he got caught up did
certain stuff he's not even crying about
getting out
he still want to do something productive
while here while he's in there yeah put
him on a compound let him do something
productive same thing yet still you use
his pants against him and keep him
locked up behind that wall and and keep
him isolated well he can't be effective
to trying to help this same thing with
larry who
do give him a chance and dude like i
said i wouldn't i wouldn't be speaking
on these dudes if if i feel like they do
some crime credit some do these dudes
number one i respect them because they
mean they ain't scared of nothing and
number two i respect them because they
got a good heart number three because
they made a conscious decision that hey
man i'm tired of seeing these children
getting hurt i'm tired of seeing this
thing going on these these are my people
these are my people i don't like this
now i don't like this him and and and i
can't i understand him because i love my
people yeah and i definitely understand
what they're going through man
and i just you know i pray i pray one
day he'll get that opportunity but they
they're different individuals you know
i've been around some who who
who still unforgiving and still like
that so that's why i know the difference
i got some don't care the world burned
right now i've been around some don't
care if the world burned but those
individuals
nah they
they just they they punish them because
they pass but those dudes want to be
part of something different we all got
gifts from god
and and and like i said god is a god who
reap his way do not sword well he may
plant talk to somebody i may come here
and water it then somebody may see them
reap it so whatever part we do it if
we're doing it for the benefit of the
children especially doing it on the
guard then it's just as important as my
part it's just as important as his part
you know saying do what our assignment
is his assignment may be to pass him out
hanging [ __ ] my sign need to pass my
chicken this side me to pass my water
don't waste our time watching what he's
doing and miss our own assignment
whatever god to put in your heart to do
as long as he's doing something you know
i i mean i'm personally i'm not a
believer in racing to the church house
and passing somebody that's got a wreck
or a god got a flat on the side of the
road yeah it's out there in front of you
yeah that's out there in front of me i
think god said you know
matthew 12 28
32 down to 42 that this you didn't do
for the least of my brothers you didn't
do for me also so i mean that's that's
my thing if i see somebody need some
help i'll do it right there and if i get
a chair to minister they'll i'll
minister right there and if i don't get
the opportunity then i keep on moving
but i'm not gonna force it on nobody
because the help is coming regardless
you know what i'm saying i'm gonna give
to them regardless
but if they opened up to that but i'm
not gonna force anything on them that's
why when i speak to these children by
different things i don't want
the enemy to be able to use it said well
he just talking to christians or he's
just talking to this type of people he's
just talking i'm talking to everybody
i'm saying i'm talking to everybody who
willing to listen on slowing down on
some of this violence what is your goal
you know what i'm saying you got the
wrong you got a bolder city roadmap and
you try to navigate through shreveport
and you're trying to wonder why you keep
running into roadblocks yeah you got the
wrong roadmap you see i'm saying you
know i can't tell you what how to choose
your life and going on but i do know
that that's sensitive violence don't
make sense you know what i'm saying it
don't make sense and they're only going
to bring you think it's specifically the
violence like that's i mean the violence
is not going to allow you to accomplish
any kind of goal you want i ain't never
seen a man and
i was dying they were there at chapel i
would die in there with the two of them
they forgot they made that they got 15
million on the books they had to eat the
same soups i eat they had either in the
supermax you got the t the unit bomber
all them people they these folks
got got
some of these dudes got million dollars
on a book but they got to make the same
store that i make so what good it do you
to be a millionaire and you're sitting
up in jail that's right so it serves you
no purpose and that's the thing about it
is align yourself with your goals okay
what your goal is to make money you
can't make money if you every few
minutes you have been buying you're
burning yourself out of jail or you're
getting a lawyer or you got a murder
case and going on you know what i'm
saying eventually you're gonna when you
when you get unlucky you're lucky if you
if you if you get out of jail on them
when you finally get unlucky you're
gonna be dead
either way it goes you're not trying to
you know your goal don't make sense you
got a self-destructive goal cause i used
to laugh at the nerds and people nerds
in the square that were going to work
and going on when i was sitting in jail
i realized they were smarter than me
yep you feel the same huh yeah
cause it was fun right i mean it was fun
while a lot like if you if you look back
in the early 90s late 80s
you know i mean if you if you think
about that life
was it fun were you anxious were you
nervous like what was that life like it
was it was fun because you having to you
know you're having it your way you know
you able to go anywhere you want to go
do what you want to do you can go spend
four or five thousand dollars over here
and then when you come back you may have
ten thousand waiting on you or twenty
thousand waiting on you yes that was
that was fine
but
it was consequences behind it and then
it was it was your conscious too because
you got to watch
you got to watch the jockers you got to
watch the polices you got to watch the
uh the snitches
you watching everybody
you always constantly watching everybody
do you feel like you were happy back
then i wasn't happy
i thought i was
oh i thought i was happy with the nice
all the diamond rings on and the gold
changes and the big cadillac and jag
well yeah i thought i was happy
but when i went to jail i realized i
wasn't happy at all
because at night time when you wait when
you go to bed
and you know hoping nobody don't
well really i won't worry about the guys
i'm hoping the police don't kick my doe
down yeah that's one more i ain't
worried about nobody else i'm worried
about the police
you know
and you're always looking over your
shoulder you're watching everybody you
know what i mean for
polices you know you got to watch
everybody because you don't know who
they is
uh well i could sort of spoil it
i just i used to spot them a little bit
you know but
but you you constantly you're constantly
watching over your shoulder
and now i don't have to do that yeah you
know i'm at peace i could i could just
rip and run now like i want i ain't got
to worry about the police kicking my
door down and all that type of mess
cause
if you kick my door down a knife you
don't kill me up in that house yeah i
want a whole lot of your money yeah yeah
there you go you ain't got no better
coming in here right right and knowing
that there's peace of mind in that right
ain't nobody doing nothing wrong in my
house uh-huh yeah uh-huh yeah so yeah
i'm good now i'm hey i'm more
comfortable now than i was when i was
since i was about what about
24-25
you know do you remember a specific
moment being locked up facing that the
totality of that where you felt humbled
or were you just taken moment by moment
or this was a reality you already knew
was potentially coming given sort of
what was going on in your lives
locking
i had been doing time since farm school
so a lot getting locked up didn't humble
me it's when i got
when i got shot up
over on uh
jueller
and they had pronounced me doa
you know
they had they wasn't expecting me to
live because the police officer had got
shot at the same spot that i had got
shot he had a bulletproof vessel and he
died just a week before the year at that
same place no at the same time but in
the same location same location that's
why they kept turning me over all night
because they couldn't understand how the
bullet went around my heart
and came out the back
you were shot eight times that or not
eight separate times yeah now yeah i was
i said i got 11 bullet holes i was shot
like four different times
uh but i had grabbed the gun i was
trying to take the gun when i couldn't
take the gun i was just trying to unload
it so make sure it couldn't be couldn't
be shot but long story short um
that that that humbled me because the
lady come there and she said switchboard
later she said baby you know they've
been she know they've been turning you
over
they've been coming to here mess with
you all night because they jump out boy
remember to jump out boy got killed yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's that's that's
he ain't gotta hit the same play i mean
that's the baby they keep turning you
over cause they can't figure out how how
the bullet went around your heart it
wasn't nothing for him to bounce off her
and she said baby whatever you do when
you get up don't leave the lord in his
bed when you leave so
and that's why
when i when i got there and then my
dudes came and got me my sons came and
got me they kidnapped me at the hospital
that night and they took me took me to
the house and so when they took me to
the house so i kept thinking about that
and that's when after then i started
cooking at the house i wasn't going out
that much i started cooking i had failed
back i started cooking at the halls
cause my
i don't know something had happened man
something she said don't leave the lord
in this bed yeah she just got beautiful
but i i heard it when they had i
couldn't see when i got hit and i i said
i can't see right so
the whole other stuff went down but
anyway i'm going across the screen all i
can see is the light and i passed by
this house and it felt like a felt like
a church
so i i went and i put my jimmy under
there
and you know i knocked on the door and i
said ma'am uh what y'all calling i'm
lying for me but i gave him a fake name
then i gave my wife the real name they
said babe why you saying your name it's
eric taylor i should call they probably
won the game and got me if i had said
sebastian rich
and then so that's when i heard the
little boy or something a kid about 14
years old and back said mom this bam bam
bam bam bam man you got a big hole in
your back man i got you man i got you
and my wife had told us to make sure
they take him to willis knight dog
if he'd be unconscious when they got
there but they came then they put me
they put this this suit around me and
they blow it up with hell
they put like a vest around me to seal
up all the holes and they blew it up
with air yeah and i remember one police
lady said bam bam come on you scrolling
this you've been through moon it's him
cause i was paralyzed once before what a
bullet had hit me i still got a bullet
in my hip for that
but anyway long story short
they took me there when they took me
that's when i went up i don't go into
the story about the stuff i see but i
went up through the ambulance when i
went up through the ambulance i seen a
lot of stuff
but anyway but when i when i came back
in that last i heard heard uh every one
of the uh emts saying the prognosis
the prognosis of prob some of this entry
alone said this would be a doa so we
called and they called in i heard him
that's when i i shot back in my body and
i was like man you told me dude we're
praying lord you give me another chance
i ain't gonna do nothing wrong no more
long without leaving yeah
yeah
i was praying
hey how about that so that that uh
police officer was saying bam bam you
tougher than this she's black chicken my
my so everybody who helped me my sister
took my flower in a card wow by the next
day but anyway she yeah she's black
chick with uh
with glasses on
my sister took her car she knew who she
was she took the ladies at the house
cards and plant about to let boy bicycle
but anyway they uh
and they they [ __ ] when the dude said
that and i looked up and i said man i
can i ain't dead i can see i can read
your name tag he looked and i said yeah
your name tag said kelly then he said
then he called back and told him to get
something get something to get get the
stuff stacked this and that he's gonna
yeah and they start working there man
they got me got me up there and that's
when they got my wife they sent my wife
up there
telling my wife that they wanted me to
uh they wanted to wheel me down to the
uh
wheel me down there in the hospital
because they said
the doctors were scared to work cause
they had too many people at the hospital
it's a half of the people trying to find
out who shot me and the other half where
the people trying to explain that they
didn't have nothing to do with me
getting shot so
they said the whole hospital
going on
i ain't know nothing about none of this
oh really you didn't know nothing i mean
you knew he got shot that time though
right
oh really not then
i ain't never know him getting shot but
one time yeah that was on fourth street
no no this before ford that's you know
what i'm saying i ain't even know that
it's gorgeous station over there on
jueller yeah that wasn't all without
kept on shooting you man huh who's
shooting you man i'll be i'll be happy
to try to take the guns
getting bullets off the street
yeah
somebody come out with a gun back there
my motto used to be
you ain't gonna piss the wood man you
ain't gonna shoot me without me trying
to take it so
that was just the life i lived at that
time
have you ever seen an act uh some
something a police officer has done that
that i mean i imagine that you you have
love for that woman for saying that to
you at that moment no i i mean it's
that's that's the thing about it is like
i told you my sister is a police officer
and i know some i mean i respect police
officers who listen we
as as as as a community as a people we
need police officers you know i'm saying
we're not against police officers i
don't think none of us ever been against
police officers we get people who get
behind their uniform and don't do their
job and be dirty use that uniform as
excuse to be abusive towards folk but
anytime a police come down and did his
job he never had no trouble same way you
would be if there was somebody in the
neighborhood if there's somebody in the
neighborhood who's getting over on the
elderly or doing something wrong with
the kids that wouldn't happen in the
neighborhood exactly but as far as the
police come down there and did stuff and
we ain't got any if you do something and
that police take you to jail
so right now in this city when you got
the murder rate you know reaching the
the highest it's reached you know in the
history of the city and and and the
violence is just going off and it seems
like senseless and completely
unorganized and making um it's just
tragic and all ends like what role did
the police have in this like what what
would you like to see the police they
they lost it they lost
their credibility they lost their
credibility so without their credibility
it's going to take mans
who from the streets to be able to get
the credibility and they need to start
trying to resolve some of these
situations to get these kids to
understand that every augment don't have
to end in the depth every argument don't
have to you know you going to jail and
somebody going to hell and that's what
people need to get them to understand
that being a gangster mean also thinking
so don't sit here but the police have
most of the police department with some
of the stuff the children been seeing
and stuff
they have lost their credibility then
they hired all these young officers who
you know no disrespect to the police and
everything but they hide from what they
can and going on and they're not
properly trained so now they gung-ho and
you know they want to come there and
talk bad to people going on they have no
they go around and they do that lock and
knocking stuff and going on but people
don't even respect that because even the
way they do that you know you can do
stuff you can do a good thing and do it
in such an ugly manner to it no longer
have no credibility yeah so how do they
get that credibility back i mean the
first thing is they need to start
finding credible people
to do things and help them do things and
be a part of that with them so then they
can piggyback off their credibility
and then they can start becoming
credible themselves if they go out there
you can't just sit here and say okay
you've been you just i just seen you
shoot a dude down in the back or half
your officer shoot a dude down in the
back and you turned your head or you
went along with him and going on then
you're dirty and rotten there's no hope
for you right but i mean but but
with with somebody yeah go sorry go
ahead under under the cold under the
blue cold
me and how you say this in jail
i used to see officers come there
work working there those dudes was they
was they was i could see them before
they got turned
those guys
came there with the objective of doing
their job and being fair but the
association brought about assimilation
because they got with dirty officers and
under they blew code they had to turn
their head
and going on they had to turn their head
to this or they
they amen this amen that's wrong and
going on so now you amen then so you
didn't become dirty and now those
officers there now they they lost their
credibility because the people that seen
it and they screeched and talked and the
street is talking ah man what oh he want
to talk to you ain't going to talk to me
he was just with that also shot to do it
in the back last week and he got on tv
and said the dude was coming at him and
we showed video show to do wasn't coming
at him and going on they lost they the
whole forces allowed their credit bills
like i said they had they need to team
up with some of the dudes from the hood
the pastors in the community pastors who
who know the peop in community and do
some things to to establish that
credibility it ain't got to be the whole
police force the ones who really want to
be a part and want to be able to go down
there and talk to people let the pastor
and let the that the dude show them how
to invest in these people's lives and
once they start investing in these
people live and so and see and each year
and feel comfortable coming to them and
saying hey listen uh this is the problem
i got or hey what do i do about this
because you i mean you do need them i
mean you need you got to have it but
when you're i mean for both of y'all
when you're in prison i mean there were
ceos that did right by you right that
that you could trust that did it like
you said if somebody came in and talked
to you and used reason every single time
you leave bernard told me on his own his
own officer lieutenant bernard
told me say hey listen man i don't feel
comfortable with you going down there
without that camera cause some of these
are some of these lieutenants they're
being hurt you man so he the one told me
to start making sure that i get the
camera brought down there by any means
necessary which is why you refused to
cuff up when they came to yourself
exactly this is lieutenant and i
respected blue tiller and then but
lieutenant bernard and gassed me a
couple of times and every time he didn't
get me i respect every minute of it
because he did everything by the book
he did everything by the book he did if
other ones that had got me in the rage
and we looked and i was too [ __ ] on
when he got there
he gonna do his job he's gonna gas me
and going on but i respect it cause he's
gonna do everything by the book it's
really just about in the same thing on
the streets right now shining a light on
those ones and being like that
look at what that will get you yeah look
at what that will get you and then what
they but they have to stand up when they
stand up it's just like with with
but that goes both ways when dude like
lieutenant bernard his own
why am i like homie maybe be doing
something clown in the stupid i tell him
i listen man hey
don't do that on bernard he's straight
up dude that's right straight up don't
don't that's right they go both ways
that's right that's right i said no
don't do that to him and would you guys
be willing to sort of do that for the
police now if they doing their job and
going on yeah if one
dude going on yeah we come on man don't
don't give him all that little man just
doing the job come on we do that we do
that all the time and would you do that
in the bottoms
back in the day
yeah i mean were there any were there
any police back then that you feel like
well we had see that area had very few
because it was a picnic to them they
came down there and they just had fun
but if if you had one whether they been
the bottom of anywhere else you had one
that came down there doing this job we
we had no problem with them you had a
matter of fact what that one the grave
was not gray here the other one
yeah
now with the [ __ ] here remember he's
called you come by there and go get him
[ __ ]
yeah i know you had a family guy yeah
the old guy he's coming
he'd go in and get him a sandwich to
come out and hey
he come back and five dudes will be
standing right there ready ready to turn
themself into him then they born right
on out of jail and going about their
business damn
dude uh dennis are we good on t no
yeah yeah yeah yeah we could we could we
could we we could do more we're gonna do
more we don't want me in trouble yeah he
should be able to climb up look at that
look at that you gotta climb up the wall
[Music]
thanks for being here everybody i really
appreciate it if you dug what you saw
and you want to hear more subscribe like
do all that stuff uh it'd mean a lot to
us i hope you dig these episodes as much
as we dig doing them you guys take care
of yourself